we pray for all the candidates that
their hearts will be open to you a
crowded political race can be a burden
for everyone and at Ebenezer AME Church
in Charleston there Phoenix praying for
clarity
people are black-white rich-poor no
candidate is inspiring sermons here but
in South Carolina loyalty can outweigh
ideology and that may be enough for Joe
Biden he's banking on african-american
voters reviving his campaign I think I'm
going back I think I'm going blind so I
don't know what how long my weeks I'm
feeling in the morning but it would for
this right now
that's who I'm voting for right now he's
good enough yes well he is but he's not
going to I can assure you I decided what
do you think of Bernie Sanders
I love Bernie Sanders I do but Bernie is
just not the man Biden has history in
this state Bernie Sanders team claimed
they have the future every young kid I'm
talking to there for Bernie I have not
met one young person here who's for
another candidate other than Bernie
Caroline and Greg have come all the way
from Brooklyn New York to knock on doors
they believe Bernie's base is way
broader than their liberal anklet I
think that he showed in Nevada that he
has a pretty broad base this is a good
test but I do think that like if you
show a bunch of ads that show you within
pictures with Obama and talk about the
fact that you were vote one was vice
president it's gonna be very easy to
suggest and get polls that say that
you're like super strong and Bernie
super weak with black voters I think the
message that Bernie's saying should
resonate with
and especially black people that have
been disenfranchised and marginalized so
we'll see but the polling suggests the
frontrunners rival will be the one
getting the light and lift here just as
his White House bid appeared to be
splattering to an unceremonious end
there are still signs of life for Joe
Biden a resounding victory here would
give him some much-needed momentum into
Super Tuesday 14 states is a long slog
though one weighty win is more about
survival than success and a wild upset
and could sink him
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Charleston South
Carolina